hey
congratulations how's it feel to finally
but be back on solid ground
it's uh it's kind of strange to be home
again after such a long time
i'm just happy to be back with my family
back in my pets it's been great
it took much longer than we were
anticipating when we first spoke to you
it did so i was supposed to be back in
mid-october and then i was stuck in
alaska for a month i was stuck in russia
for a month because of visa and weather
problems but i'm finally back it took a
bit longer than i was hoping but yeah
and with two guinness world records is
that right tell me about them
that's right so i am now the youngest
woman to fly sail around the world and
the youngest person to fly certainly
around the world in microlight so it's
basically an extra small plane with a
few extra like limitations
what um what inspired you to do this in
the first place
so at first i'd always dreamt of flying
around the world but i just assumed that
it'd be too complicated too dangerous
too expensive so i never really thought
much about it and then i was finished
finishing school and i thought actually
this is the perfect time to do something
crazy and fly around the world so i
planned the route which basically
consisted of me grabbing a pen and a
world map and just kind of drawing where
i wanted to go
and then the next big step was finding
sponsorship so this whole trip has been
self-funded and then icdsoft a web
hosting company from bulgaria came on
board and helped support me
what inspired you as i said um you
talked about the fact that you felt that
you couldn't do it
or it was going to be too expensive and
then when you were
taking part in the journey what inspired
you to continue on because there must
have been moments when you thought i
can't do this i've had enough
definitely i think alaska and russia
were really tricky every flight was
really challenging whether it was
turbulence or just poor weather
and it really helped sometimes i get
messages from people saying uh zara you
know i saw what you were doing and
you've inspired me to start flying as
well and that was great so that would
really kind of um help me to keep going
because i thought actually i'm having a
bit of a positive impact on some people
so clearly i'm doing something right
were there any particularly memorable
parts of the journey when you were about
to take off or land or you were up and
it was just you and and very little
noise around you looking down and
thinking yeah this is cool
oh hundred percent i flew every active
volcano in iceland which was incredible
as you could kind of see the lava
flowing out that was amazing marines
beautiful siberia was fascinating
because i would fly for hundreds of
miles without seeing anything human
or human-made so no roads no electricity
cables no villages obviously it was
quite scary though because if the engine
were to stop suddenly i'm stuck in minus
35 degrees celsius hours away from
rescue so that was quite scary and then
some of the more political stuff so i
had to fly along
the border of north korean airspace
which was really interesting and quite
scary as well
but every country was gorgeous
what could you you might have been shot
down from north korea is that what
you're thinking right no so apparently
they test missiles uh with no warning
and although the risk is tiny there is a
risk so i thought well let's play it
safe and kind of fly along japanese
airspace rather than north korean
airspace i think that's very wise how
often did you manage to be in touch with
your family your mother's heart must
have been in her mouth the whole time
right yeah a little bit i think uh i
tried to explain them every single day
sometimes i was trickier in some
countries there was limited access to
wi-fi and internet
otherwise i had a satellite phone but
again in russia it was so cool like i
had to use it outside and because it was
so cool i could only phone my parents
for about five or ten minutes before my
my fingers would start to hurt
so what's next for you zara you're home
in brussels i'm sure that you had extra
big hugs when you got back um you need a
while to get over what's happened what's
next
for me the next big step will be getting
a degree probably i'd love to study
engineering at university and at the
same time hoping to you know keep talk
to people about my experiences and as
long as i can keep encouraging more
women to gain aviation right now only
five percent of uh commercial pilots are
women and i'm hoping to get that number
up
i think i knew that statistic already
it's unbelievable isn't it what about
going into space do you fancy that
that'd be pretty cool yeah i drew my
used to go to space one day but i need
to get a degree first and then that's
its own challenge so okay so what are
you gonna do did you say engineering
that's right engineering engineering
fantastic in brussels in belgium or in
the uk probably the uk or the us i'm
still waiting on the results so we'll
see what happens oh i'm sure you
absolutely nailed it it's good to talk
to you let us know how you get on won't
you
thank you
okay take care thank you